let's say I have one molar of let me
pick a strong acid let's say it's
hydrochloric acid hydrochloric acid HCL
and we know of course that since it's a
strong acid it disassociates completely
so HCl and an aqueous solution or a
solution of water disassociates
completely into hydrogen ions in an
aqueous solution which is really
hydronium I've said that multiple times
plus your chlorine anion in an aqueous
solution so if you actually have a molar
of this as soon as you put it in the
water you really have one molar of this
so your hydrogen concentration is really
one molar and of course we know that
what's the pH D what's the pH of that
well the pH is just the minus log base
10 of your hydrogen concentration which
is one which is the minus log of zero so
minus zero which is equal to zero so
your pH is going to be equal to zero and
let's say for it for use and lit in the
later part of this let's say I have a a
liter of this right this just tells me
how many moles per liter and now I just
told you that I have one liter so I
actually you know you have one mole so
let me make a little chart here now make
a little box here and let's make this
axis right here this is going to be my
pH and right when I take that first
measurement let's say this is zero here
this is seven and this is 14 up here
when I take that first measurement my
flute my solution of hydrogen chloride
or hydrochloric acid has a pH of zero
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
titrate this acid this aqueous solution
of acid and titrate just means drop
something else into it in in controlled
increments to see what happens and this
is called an acid what were I'm doing
here is it's going to be an acid-base
titration I have an acid here what I'm
actually going to titrate it with or the
reagent that I
going to add to it and the word reagent
multi the reagent is essentially a
reactant that you're that when you view
it this way that you're adding to the
solution so it's the titrant so in this
case my solution already has
hydrochloric acid in it the pH is
already zero but what I'm going to do is
I'm going to add a strong base I'm going
to add a strong base let's say sodium
hydroxide that's my favorite strong base
and let's say I have a solution that I
have prepared ahead of time let's say
it's a let's say it's a one molar
solution one molar solution but I'm not
going to add all of it at the same time
I'm going to add it in increments of a
tenth of a liter so let's say it's a so
this is this is one liter that I've
added it and then this would be two
liters so this is so this would be 500
milliliters 500 ml this is one liter
this is 1.5 liters this is two liters
and so on this axis I'm going to slowly
add more and more of this hydroxide so
what's going to happen as I add let's
say I add let's add five I slowly add as
I slowly add hydroxide it's going to
increase the pH why is it going to
increase the pH because this o H
remember hydroxide is a strong acid a
strong base so the NaOH disassociates
completely in an aqueous solution to O H
- plus sodium cation right now if I'm
adding this to this stuff here what's
what he thinks gonna happen well this
stuff right here these OHS are just
going to stop up your hydrogen's so for
the most part obviously everything is
probabilistic and whenever we're dealing
with chemistry there's always some
molecules that won't completely react
and there'll always be some
concentration of anything and that's why
you actually can never get to a zero
concentration of hydrogen no matter how
much base you add because there will
always be some hydrogen molecules that
are that that are just hiding just
perfectly or they're in perfect
equilibrium so they don't react but most
of them will read
but so as I add more H these are going
to disappear so my hydrogen
concentration is going to go down the pH
is the negative log of that so your pH
will go up your pH will go up slowly
slowly
well it looks slowly because it's a log
chart so maybe it's doing something like
this your pH concentration is gonna look
something like as you add more and more
but you might say oh that's such a slow
movement why is it occurring faster but
you have to think about something this
right here if this is if this is one if
this is a pH of one this means so at a
pH of zero this means your hydrogen
concentration is 1 molar at a pH of 1
this means your hydrogen concentration
is at 10 to the minus 1 which is 0.1
molar so even though on a log chart it
looks like it looks like you would have
you've made a very small movement you've
actually gone by a factor of 10 in terms
of your reduction of your hydrogen
concentration so roughly by the time
you've added added you started off with
1 molar of your your hydrogen by the
time you've added roughly 900
milliliters of your of your solution you
probably would have gotten rid of most
of it and obviously the denominators
changing because I'm actually adding
volume here right because I'm actually
adding this some volume here so you'd
have to add them but you get the idea
that these these actual molecules of
hydroxide are going to react with these
things they're going to essentially turn
into water and disappear into the
solution but it's going to lower your so
these are going to disappear with that
with those disappearing for the most
part which leads in an overall reduction
concentration of your hydrogen ions
which will lead to an increase in your
pH until some point where you've pretty
much stopped up as many of these things
as you can there'll always be a few of
them but you've stopped up as many of
them as you can and so any incremental
hydrogen you add or any incremental
hydroxide you add will actually go to
build the hydroxide concentration where
the hydroxide concentration is going to
be greater than your hydrogen
concentration but even better than that
there's going to be some point where
you've added just enough of this
that you have an equal amount of this
and this you have an equal amount of
hydroxide and hydrogen right and if you
think well what happens first of all
when there's there's an equal amount of
hydroxide and hydrogen well then you're
neutral right if if your hydroxide
concentration is equal to your hydrogen
concentration you you're a neutral this
is just like water you're at a pH you're
at a pH of seven so there's some point
where your hydroxide concentration is
equal to your hydrogen concentration and
your pH is going to be seven and then
above that you're just adding more and
more hydroxide the hydroxide
concentration is overwhelming your
hydrogen concentration and so you're
gonna get really really basic and since
this is a strong base you're eventually
going to get to a pH of 14 because
you're essentially going to have well
you're not gonna have one molar let me
erase that point you're gonna have half
a molar of OHS at the end of this so
your graph is gonna look something like
this it's going to look something like
this this is when that's kind of you can
kind of use it and up here now I mean
you're still gonna have hydrogen
concentration what's gonna go really
small it's gonna get really really
really really small now what what's
interesting about what just happened
here at this point right here your Oh
your Oh H is equal to your hydrogen and
the way I think about it is all of your
all of your the great majority of your
of your moles of hydrogen were sucked up
at that point so in order to stop up one
mole of hydrogen you essentially for the
most part and these are there's always
things that don't get completely stopped
up but you'll essentially have to add
one mole so you're essentially gonna
have to add one mole one mole of O h2
SAAP up your one mole of hydrogen
remember this is one molar and you had
one liter of it so you had one mole of
hydrogen to stop up one mole so you need
one mole of O H to stop up and how do
you get one mole of O H well we said
that the the concentration of this
solution was one molar so once you put a
liter in there
because that's one mole per liter once
you put a leader in there you would have
put one moles of hydroxide cations in
there to stop up the hydrogen so this
was the point this is the equivalence
point where you've essentially you have
an equal amount and very low
concentrations of both hydroxide and
hydrogen you've essentially sopped up
all of the hydrogen but you also have
sopped up all of the hydroxide that
you've added so far after this point any
hydroxide you add will essentially
contribute to increasing the pH even
more or it'll it'll kind of overwhelm
your hydrogen concentration now what's
interesting about this in this example I
told you oh I have hydrochloric acid and
I gave you it's concentration ahead of
time but let's say I didn't tell you
that let's say it was some mystery
substance and you just measured the
mystery substances pH at this point you
said okay its pH is zero and you
titrated it with this sodium hydroxide
and you said gee when I added one mole
because you figured out at a liter of
this solution I've added 1 mole of
hydroxide ions at that point I've
essentially eliminated all of the
hydrogen ions that were in my original
solution so I must have had 1 mole of
whatever acid this was over here so this
would have told you that my initial
concentration was 1 mole one mole of H+
and since we know it's easy to see how
much volume you have you say I have a
leader so you say oh my original
concentration of this acid is 1 molar
and you could also know that what you
have what you're dealing with is a
strong acid because it's a strong acid
and maybe this will and I encourage you
to watch the next video where I do the
same thing with a weak acid but because
it's a strong acid and a strong base
reacting with each other when you have
the same number of moles of both you get
exactly to a pH of 7 they completely
neutralize each other and you're into it
you have a completely neutral solution
if you had a strong base with a weak
acid the strong base once you have the
same amount as the weak acid it would
have neutralized it but you would have
also had some of the conjugate weak base
left so you would actually ended up with
a basic PA
I'm gonna do that in the next video but
if you see that the equivalence point if
you see the equivalence point occurs at
a pH of seven you know that you were
titrating what you were dealing with was
a wheat with a strong acid because it
was completely neutralized not more than
neutralized by the strong base and what
you do is you look at D and if you
wanted I ball where is the equivalence
point you look for the steepest point in
the graph because that's the point where
you're going from having a majority of
hydrogen versus hydroxide to having a
majority of hydroxide versus hydrogen so
it creates this inflection in the graph
and you just would have to look at this
trying to say oh I added a liter of the
solution the concentration of the
solution is one mole per liter it's one
molar has a molarity of one so I must
have added 1 mole of hydroxide to get to
this point so I must have neutralized
one mole of hydrogen so there must have
been one mole of hydrogen to begin with
one mole of hydrogen and since I had one
liter of solution I had one mole of
hydrogen and one liter of solution so my
original molarity was one anyway I don't
want to confuse it too much in the next
video I'm gonna try to do the same thing
but I'm gonna do it with a weak acid